The Joe Rogan Experience just wanted to
go home I wanted my daughter
to [ __ ] see the things I saw as a kid
not North Jersey type [ __ ] but I wanna
did you see that [ __ ] special on uh
the amusement park and we were kids and
from Verona no Jersey what's the name
action park no they ended up calling a
class action park
that's dull what happened that's what we
used to go we were kids yeah every time
you went there they take you out of neck
brace [ __ ] it when you were a kid dog
please Jamie if you find anything a
trailer dude I was at a [ __ ] one of
those fairs they would pull up in a
parking lot look at this [ __ ] when we
were kids you know Jesus Christ you're
flying down these things how many kids
got broken legs oh my God every time you
went there if you went with a kid
somebody was going the most dangerous
New Jersey or running in New York oh my
God people are jumping off cliffs
whoa you could drive that [ __ ] race cars
everything you could what is this bungee
jumping this was the 70s with the class
action pool that was like Palisade
amusement park it's a it's a pool that's
like a big cops probe look at this [ __ ]
look parked accident so people just got
in accidents all the time oh every other
weekend look at it
but is that okay here's the question
when I was a kid I didn't go out to play
I won't have to die big difference okay
these little [ __ ] half a fruitcakes
today
I went out to die remember you hug your
mother and [ __ ] like you I've been good
I don't know we're gonna go rob a train
I don't know what's gonna happen but
look at this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is so
ridiculous and New York had a ton of
these when we were kids from tuxedo New
York all the way down
oh my God
that's hilarious
Action Park you got to watch the doc why
was this so here's the question if you
could go like if you guys are doing like
BMX flips you know guys are practicing
for those things how many of those guys
get hurt
a lot right how often they get hurt
well why is it okay if they get hurt but
it's not okay if you go to a park where
you're reasonably certain you have a
good chance of getting hurt
like if if it's basically people paying
to have the same kind of risk factor as
you would do if you were doing something
else crazy
that's totally okay like why can't you
you know what I'm saying like you can
get a BMX bike that can be a ramp people
know you're gonna jump it everybody
knows that's fine but
that what is that more of a commitment
because you went you got a helmet you
got a bike and you got the whole thing
instead of just going to this place this
should be a place where it's [ __ ]
risky right this should be a like if
somebody had if you had a lock down
solid contract where no matter what
happened to you you couldn't sue them
they could make a place like that again
but I don't think they would ever be
able to hold you gotta Watch the
documentary
I remember watching it yeah it's
tremendous but is it is it negligence
yes oh if I remember correctly there's a
lot of people telling them you can't do
this for kids and people like give a
[ __ ] it's the 80s we're doing coke we're
making money have fun but they're
jumping off cliffs like that thing like
the fact that they had a cliff dive
like that's just crazy they built a
cliff dive and you pay people could just
jump like if you hit if you're Drive
jumping off of this is the big thing
that that was their member the bridge
where everybody would like get drunk and
jump off of and people were getting hurt
they're landing on each other all the
time oh of course look at that I can
imagine that they would I bet imagine
people landed on each other on purpose
well I think that's the part of it
because they would cheer it'd be like
you're the you're the man for the five
minutes of the summer day that's a great
way to break your neck
it's a great way to break your neck
it's really good I think there's even a
fictionalized version that giant
Knoxville made that's why he popped up
in that thing I don't remember
you know these places and and it was the
70s late 70s early 80s 70s I don't think
the insurance regulations were as strict
as they are today
like they didn't have a [ __ ] idea
open up a park yeah whatever just give
me 900 a month to send this a check on
the first
what kind of places it's like Seaside
you know it's nice couple little swings
here's a question